こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんまた記憶
には新しいのではないでしょうか私ですね
今年の夏ぐらいに寝超大型企画で1億円の
つかみ取りやっ
られたんですよやめたって言うとなんか
そのなんか被害者みたいな感じになっ
ちゃいますけど僕が主催したのは間違い
ないし僕が皆さんに行っていただいては
間違いないんですけどまぁ被害者です機
会社という言葉もちょっと語弊があります
けどまぁ簡単に言うとイチョウ県の
つかみ取りさせていろんな方がすごい浅尾
が持っていかれたというなんかあの置き
karu さん金とプロで分かれている
カリズマ-1軽さんっていう
ユーチューバーさんがいらっしゃるんです
けどもあの方の誕生日プレゼント擦れてて
その誕生日プレゼントのその大返しの
誕生日プレゼントとああいってきます
なんと落差したでしょ
[音楽]
指定しますねこれん
どうしたけれども以上でまず
30分遅刻してしまいます乗ろうとした
宅地がパンクしちゃってダメだったけど
凄いなそんな小樽や光と疑われそうだ
トップ3の動画を撮ってきたんでやめ
じゃっ注目ですねハッハッ中毒者に何度も
いいやいいよいやーほんとんっていうかも
知れませんよね
今だってそのチャンネルとか1000万人
間近で
昨日通りだやりタイムであの2000万人
と止める件についてねあみられたんですか
そう見てブザーで3万くらいでとって増え
ましたねありがとうございますそんな時期
に通したな
彼は若くないですか川根ダーマペンって
いうですねダウンタイム中でまた歌いミツ
ハリオてしまうって傷をつけてなんか
めっちゃ綺麗になるって聞いたことあり
ますめっちゃがあればええいいな始めても
肌綺麗なまぁいやいやさん
ホンダ聞かさ
もちろんチャンネル登録先戦までも大事な
んですけど
光さん通りには
もっと大事なことがあるんだと思いまして
デー
話を戻すとですよあの小久保誕生日があり
ましたとうん
今年2月で光る産地のいって皆さんが
お誕生日プレゼントを買ってくれましたと
ありがとうございます
で
でそのお返しとして
いつ行ったっけ8月9月でそうですね
ひかるさんのお誕生日プレゼント
遅れてしまったという事で盛大にあるさん
にはタダで打つ億円のつかみ取りをして
いただいたところ
whああああああ
yg 優遇これ
re
ます
5000万円角飛たということでまあまあ
ねこれはレンズめちゃくちゃ聞かれねえ
どうなったんですかっていう声はあって
そうクレアめっちゃくれほんまに結果で
本当にちゃんとあったもらったのっていう
もらったんだとしたらどうするのっていう
のはうチェック的に
クルト
全く一緒ですねその検知でこの話ってそう
なんですよあのー私にあのやっぱり光るさ
に縁を切られましたっていう動画から反省
しまして a
まあまあある旨大家ですやっぱりちょっと
しっかりとそのどうなってるのっていうの
を知らせしないとまたヤジられたのって
なっちゃうんだろうなるほどちょっとご
清聴しましたこちらを取っ5000万円に
ついてはですね
実際光さん結構連絡とよっておりますね
確かじゃないんだよねはいどう使うかって
とりあえず
年内には無理ですという言葉に年ずっと
今回をつながれ年内だったと思う10日
でしたほっ塗りでしょこれ不可能ねその
5000万使って皆想像する何度も難しい
というかむずいーんすよ難しくてだから
まあ
来年
来年ですね次期もうちょっと見てでいいん
じゃ言ったところです6やってメンドーサ
が確かな市加治木見てそれから良さそう
ですねだから町初めての誕生日のきて
しまうんなんとなく僕もう
ヒアシスってどう使おうかっつっなんと
いうかイメージできてるんですけどもう
ちょっとネマニャないというか来月もどう
かちょっと色々とかなり
厳しいことをやろうとしておりますうーん
ちょっとお時間がかかるかもしれないと
いう話でございますまあいつか楽しみて
くださいって感じですよね本当に聞かれ
さんとはちゃんとあの
やらせだと思ってくださっていうか
までも結構大須の本となった方雪みたいな
のはをリアルにそのクリエイター仲間から
もう
がちなわかるわけやっぱれさすがにある
ヤラセで受けのプリーストだけないといけ
やしたわけないよあればあっ行くぞどちら
からこんなにも戸惑っているというそうな
ガチャから哀れおそらくうーむの社員
なんか笑ったブームの社員 or はて
くれゆかって言われてるこんな慌てるやっ
てことぐらいくらいかますだろあんっ
[音楽]
ブーブーもらうだけでもまあそう世界だっ
ているそうなんですよご覧じゃなくて
の一緒にする何かに
アイム所が使ってもらう
そしたら増塾関連し動画になる知っている
まぁそれが一番いいんじゃやっお互い何か
よく使える5000万円になるのかな超大
画面の妻からここで魚も請け負ってしまっ
て俺の口座に振り込まれた時点ですごいを
面倒歳いろいろ難しいやり取りをしつつ
あるサンとぼけて5000万円どうしよう
かと話しを実は進めておりましたおります
そしてそれが今年は無理です無理ですので
5000万円どうなったっていうのはもう
聞かないでくださいてくださいん
見たくないですか
もうじゃないん
[音楽]
ほんとあの年内にこれだけ引かれさんと
動画撮りたいなと思って今回お邪魔させて
いただきました yeah 全然で別もん
だ動画してるんじゃないかなと思ったけど
俺はんまだを切る際に使ってるいや言っ
ちゃまた森をどうやっパパだ俺はいつでも
取るだろうグッと飛びながらしないんだ
ファイバれづらい無双好きなら今年も光
さんと会えないかなと思ってたんで言うと
姉私たち目高めたしてんだろいや俺嬉しい
やっぱデーってきた事務所とあってくれる
応募の一人でこれをどうあるところって
どこから投函上のリョウク
どうぞ私で珍しいですよね始めたからもし
自分あり登録者多いと絡むっていうほぼ
ないかなうーん数少ない一人だ
皆さんん
俺は一人さん好きなんで
まああの俺のチャンネルからねこの者で
なかったけれども今は1000万今
ちょっとなんですのでできればそれは
もちろん気力年代達成あ受賞は本当にね
結構前から日本一として youtube
を牽引してきた一人だと思っててまあ
もちろん今はもう
事務所が取れちゃう人が何人かいるんです
よではやっぱ youtube が
盛り上がっているタイミングで羽生採用年
倉内パウダーもずっとキープしちゃってる
この人が1000万に迎えるにもうすぐ
ぜひね僕のチャンネルがケアでも登録して
ください金ないんで
すごいな2000万は行っすごいし
なんか最近
生放送するじゃないですかその他ずらすね
ラスト間に行くまで生ホップを代表するん
ですけどスイミングちょっと難しいんです
けど発足はほんとチャンネル登録者数の
数字しないからとっ
なるほどねえじゃあもうどっかやもそう
すると思います
迷っています
なんかそこ争いたいなっていうだろうね
みんなしてる際つけたいとアーマーせずに
いくってことでそうなんですよします
するんか皆さん今年はどんな1年でしたか
今年
いやーでをまあ今年は何なのか
ず50中落ちつづったっていうふうに思っ
ん
なんかも
なんか
それご相談というか安定した自然というか
特別なもう
[音楽]
el さーん2022年もどうかよろしく
お願いますお願いします沢山のチャンネル
にも動画上がっておりますのでそちらも
是非見てくださいゆかさん愛しますお願い
しますではだ
マイスター